[Music]
that was the first time et interviewed
demi lovato at the Camp Rock premiere
back in 2008 you know she has never
shied away from her struggles or demons
and these are issues that she is battled
almost her entire career my first time
doing coke I was 17 working on Disney
Channel I just wanted to fit in okay I
was scared because my mom always told me
that your heart could just burst if you
do it but I did it anyways and I loved
it it was 2008 Demi was starring
alongside the Jonas Brothers in Disney's
record-breaking movie musical Camp Rock
was one of three Disney Channel projects
she'd taken on in her teens but she got
her start at age 10 on Barney & Friends
with future BFF Selena Gomez getting to
work with the iconic Barney the Dinosaur
it was pretty cool but amidst the fun
Demi had been dealing with years of
bullying at age seven she was suicidal
Louie was really some sort of subject to
me and it's something I went through by
age nine Lovato had developed an eating
disorder I was scared
and I was looking up to these girls that
were very very thin and there was nobody
really that really set a positive
example just say hey you know it's okay
to have a healthy body and to look
normal and have curves at age 16 Demi
released her first album followed ten
months later by a second and went on her
first national tour around this time she
started using drugs to self-medicate but
substance abuse and an eating disorder
weren't the teens only struggles Demi
battled bipolar disorder and would even
harm herself
your demons you have to admit that you
have a problem first and then you can
overcome at age 18 demi entered rehab
for the first time we talked to Demi
last year at five years sober I am able
to look at what I've done and I do kind
of like sit there and think wow I'm so
glad that I got sober and I'm able to
help you baby you know like all addicts
this is a battle that you'll have to
fight every single day for the rest of
her life
[Music]